hey guys look what I play I have been
waiting for so long for this maybe don't
know after all this and where have you
been it's [ __ ] awesome you get to
walk around as an octopus who pretends
to be a dad which is amazing no you guys
a probably all watch this but I'm just
gonna show you my best bit so it's not
boring you're gonna love this this is
some of you fine so just stick in stick
it stick around that's what I meant
stick around every girl's dream she's
waiting for her prince
octopus he's just running late he's
always late maybe the fact that he's got
tentacles and he can't walk mr. groom
the wedding is starting are you ready
you're not even dressed make yourself
presentable she's waiting for you
genius key what are you doing I don't
want you I don't know one thing oh okay
right oh my god so close yet so far oh
my god even that's like a massive
achievement this game is just the best
isn't it okay right so touch your right
finger okay this
Oh God just go in okay oh look at this
cake okay find my tux
what is that see it's like both stand up
please stand up please it's not how you
stand up to PI okay it's like a
ballerina put it down put it down okay
no Hotel what I don't work your plate
down
yeah look at there now
your wife is going to oh there's the
touch you are guarding once it was a fun
guy
Oh smashing it's lovely
now to get out I think I've got this
walking down low
getting better at this
she says
I thought what he picked up this high
earlier though was that not here's AA
nice picture oh my god it's such a mess
who would marry this octopus you ready
for this guys I can you not hold it
behind you Jesus
stop moving okay you ready for this oh I
just let go of it no yeah no two hands
you [ __ ] imbecile to go I bet I'm the
only one that has ever had trouble with
this that really would not surprise me I
did it yes my bowtie okay don't get too
excited I got it
I'm so beautiful oh I dropped it come on
ah look fabulous let me work it yeah oh
he loves wonderful
wonderful formal attire on the eye
immense formal attire yes sir your way
presents my wedding and I'm gonna write
it
Niall Oh God okay she just seemed happy
I missed you and I didn't see oh I'm
gonna get the rings sorry
where is the ring where is the ring is
it a nice little box
do you need any helpful for not good
thanks I got it I got it I'm now give it
to you my darling all to this love oh no
no come on along happy over I'd get me
get me along the other side oh you look
so here to get ready don't you know this
sorry
here you go my love oh my god no not to
the foot stop at the feet just the arm
just take the [ __ ] rain oh my god
I never want to get married [ __ ] that ah
that wasn't even a ring on the [ __ ]
bracelet
it's so beautiful oh my god that was
just the introduction to the game
cool
best intro ever right active dad nobody
suspected bad
oh look now that he's finally married
he's not happy anymore what's that noise
oh oh this is just like just like before
I was never very good at this game
oh hello son hello children daddy
good morning Ariel you know yes nice to
see you sleepy huh it's not nice to see
you after all these years
so I was stargazing last night while you
were off in your meds okay and I snapped
a picture of some strange leaves it's
probably just a snot my facial as a
player but you know what if it wasn't
honey did you read my latest article I
got an interview with the mayor and I
tore him apart I think I took off a
secretary Daffy
expose corruption in the fishing
industry and I know just the ship does
sneaker I'm at my girl so now I want you
to wave your legs you just will oh okay
that works too
I'm gonna be waiting on your class
everything is a triumph stupid that's
one way of opening your fridges please
there it is
Stacy my love I got to the note oh wait
that's that's not Stacy Oh
when I called out she is Stacy I heard
some crashing from the living room
mister
you know I just leaned it last sorry
I know octopus
easy I made your coffee just the way you
like it sea salt and tartar sauce mmm
sounds something that an octopus would
drink she still has no idea I drink the
coffee I know you're in an awkward
position but just just do it for your
wife
how would sorry Oh going out for a
morning stroll I see I'll be right with
you dad so much cooler grass to mow
weeds to pull back to chop and amusement
burgers for lunch okay Stacy what are
you pouring ketchup in your brother's
drink well dear I believe on the slide
why is everything such hard work we are
not - but I never realized so we totally
it comes here with me stay safe Stacy
come play with me
and was modified for motor drivers Auto
okay I am the Barbie Oh Mike how much
you don't know how it must look so much
easier than any of them I said let's go
right to what right now okay
I'm gonna burn one of them Khan also dot
do your skipped off for the doctor
family's such a liar I did week ago they
can eat hidden securities it
ah stop dropping my burger come on the
barristers delicious mmm
they're massive how are they gonna eat
those burgers hey Dad
I saw that crazy chef diet oh no not the
chef guy he wants to eat me I'm not even
kidding
come on I see you yes this is this
sucker together son but I don't think
I'd be making it I think I'd be an
awesome dad too bad I'm a woman it's
different out of the slum
where did it go what did it go did you
see that please don't say I have to redo
that girl right like over the fence I
look super smart look at me he's facing
the wrong way why are you facing the
wrong way it's still this game makes me
makes me go weird oh my god
these noises they don't sound too good
today I'm sorry yes don't have a go at
me for trampling on your flowers because
you're asking me to do this so does he
burp when people get suspicious at him
so he is he like any nervous forever
I stuffed another lon
I did lose the lawnmower [ __ ] oh it's
[ __ ] it can you see it it's like I'm
here but I'm not here I broke the game
so I don't have a popper outro for you
guys but as you can see this video
didn't really go to plant I was going to
do the whole thing and they come up to
those tiny bits that the knowledge of
glitch happens and well I was so - funny
not to upload let me know if you want to
see more I know a lot of people are
doing it right now
but yeah just give it a like if you
liked it I'd really appreciate it
and have a lovely day or evening bye I
should do what every good Pokemon does
and I shall tackle and don't ruin the
fire